joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is somebody that i
honestly i thought of immediately
because not only did i know he was there
but i also saw him go to green bay
wisconsin where he was fed in front of
the packers crowd with his
hall of fame bust and was presented with
this hall of fame ring to go with his
jacket and the packers went out and
thumped the rams in the second half of
that game after he was honored so what a
football weekend for one of the greats
in the history of the national football
league as well as the university of
michigan our friend on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line
charles woodson how are you charles
rich man i'm doing great man you know
great how are you uh where did that
weekend rank for you in the history of
your football weekends
that was a that was a glorious weekend i
mean
unbelievable starts off on thanksgiving
with a huge raiders win
then all of a sudden we go into the
weekend and
what i feel like is a must-win game in
terms of
legacy and
you know having everything on the table
everything in front of us for the
university of michigan and they went out
there and beat our arch rivals man and i
got to tell you man i couldn't be more
proud of that team and the way that they
played man they came out with fire
intensity
passing and and you could tell man that
it meant something to them and i think
that to me is just the most important
thing um i was able to watch a special
with aidan hutchinson and josh ross uh
saturday morning and they just talked
about what the rivalry meant and those
guys you know being the seniors man and
knowing that they they just had to get
it done and they did it
um being able to you know be there for
the coin toss and be our honorary
captain
and then man hopping on the plane coming
on the green bay
see my name go up in the stadium i mean
i i don't i don't you know you ask you
know where did this weekend
uh i'll tell you what there's not many
better
[Laughter]
i mean it's just unbelievable let's
let's take uh each part uh a little bit
uh each time here charles woodson on on
the rich eisen show here let's start
let's start with the the one that you
and i share together uh the one in ann
arbor i mean it it it felt different
this year that this team was different
they were built different they're
playing differently
and that they were being coached
differently and and it
obviously this was the litmus test and
it and it passed what what what do you
think was the difference this year
compared to the previous ones charles
woodson knowing the program as well as
you do yeah yeah yeah yeah i think um
you know
rich you've been watching this game for
the past you know several years
and you know one of the things that for
me that was really glaring it seems like
um in this game especially in terms of
defense it seemed like we never adjusted
to
you know what what they were trying to
do to us or
uh look at what they were doing the week
before
and be prepared for that the week that
we played them and i think the addition
of mike mcdonald mcdonald cannot go
um he can't be under you know
understated or overstated enough
you know what he did with that group of
men and getting them to buy into what
she was doing as a coach
uh get those guys you know some of them
to play differently than they've played
before i mean if you think about uh
aidan hutchinson you know a guy who's
you know could get after the passer
better than just about anybody in the
country
and then also see him be able to drop
out in coverage and cover in the flats
and go out and make tackles and be a
presence not only in the rush game but
also tackling in space
i mean this team came out fired up and
you could tell man that they they truly
bought into it and i just you know going
back to you know watching that special
with josh ross and amy hechaten
we're talking about you know aided bad
went to michigan
uh josh ross's brother went to michigan
so they know this rivalry in and out man
they know what it
would mean for them
to go out you know beating that school
and finally you know getting back on the
right side of that scoreboard so i just
think man buying into what was going on
was the biggest difference this year
what was it like in that house what was
it like
in the house that day
oh man it was
it was great man you know for me i was
you know i was working you know before
the game working fox and you know all of
a sudden got the snow flurries coming
down yeah
you know it just it just felt like a
great day to be in the big house you
know what i mean
i kept telling the guys on the set man i
don't know what it was but i just i i
just stuck i felt differently like i
mean i don't know how the team you know
and the coaches were feeling but
something about you know that particular
day man i i could just feel it man and
the whole day on the show i just kept
mentioning to the guys that man this is
this is a business trip you know i i
hope that the team approaches it that
way because i was approaching my day in
the show as a business trip as if i was
going out there to play that game so
uh they did they called they they
treated it as a business trip
and the stadium was electric the people
came out the energy was there
and
i'm getting excited right now talking to
you
i feel like running through a door right
i do too charles that's why i wanted to
talk with you and i don't know if you're
aware of this but i'll tell you anyway
as well um you know i i've been enjoying
this win even better day after day hour
after hour it gets better it gets better
it's like thanksgiving leftovers as i
mentioned on the show the previous day
um
it tastes better every single day i
don't know if you're aware that your
wine the intercept wine is perfectly
paired with whoop ass i i opened a
bottle after that game um and and you
can pair it with whoop ass like that
game in the second half perfectly it
tasted better charles i don't know if
you're aware of that you're you're i'm
going to say i am aware of it and what's
interesting which is because for me
there's never a dull moment i'm over in
the pier wisconsin and i'm signing
bottles of intercept wine and whiskey
right now right now because we're
hearing stuff in the background it
sounds like i'm doing something
i'm signing i'm saying about it right
now and to your point yes there's a lot
of people that are picking up the wooden
wine and with the burger whiskey folks
right not only did it go down well with
the basket
we put on those guys
on saturday but also yesterday's game
yeah
in the rams i mean this this whiskey and
innocent wine is going down so well this
weekend
i got a lot of people that need it man
oh my gosh all right so then the packers
um you know what it looks like to be on
a super bowl team in green bay what does
this one look like for you right now
charles you saw it up close and personal
on sunday yeah they yeah they they look
good man and uh
you know first i'll jump on the the
defensive side of the ball um and the
way that this team is really just
getting after people
um you know i always
well not always with the last couple of
weeks i've been getting giving a lot of
love to another michigan guy rashaan
gary because he is playing absolute
lifestyle football right now you can see
his development over the last couple of
years and he's just giving him an
element especially with
darius smith in out um
he's just brought a lot to the table i
look at rashewa douglas a guy who was on
the practice squad and the raiders went
and found him and you seen him with a
pick six yesterday and how fitting they
got to have a pick six of the day that i
go into the ring and buying it something
that i used to do uh plenty of times
when i played rich so
uh this team is i think
they're they're clicking
at the right time um you know aaron
rodgers and devonta adams connection has
you know never been better um and what
about
you know randall cobb you know um
this was somebody that a-rod said he
wanted back you know
we heard him before the season talking
about guys that he didn't think he
should have been you know run out or
maybe should have been retained and that
was the guy he wanted and all he did was
come up with big plays and timely
moments yesterday so
uh when i think about this team
and what they've been going through in
terms of some of the injuries
they are finding ways to win and being
able to dominate it so
it was a beautiful win yesterday great
night to be in lambeau field
um
packers and looking good well i mean
what's your connection in terms of with
rogers uh lately um and the way he's
thinking about things because
to me and i said this on my monday show
charles that there's no better place
than green bay for aaron rodgers fans
love him they dig him even with whatever
was going on with covid you know they
love him um i know what he felt about
gurukuns but you can't deny the drafting
of aj dillon is crucial
they've lost uh i don't know i've lost
track of the number of left tackles that
they've lost and that protection held up
against the rams and what they were
bringing the grown-ass men that they
were sending his way
do you think he's going to stay i mean
what do you think his senses of
everything there in green bay right now
you know
i think that as this season has uh
played out
i would have to say colonel rogers is
going to be more and more receptive to
staying in green bay i think everything
that you know he had issues with uh was
put out there in the open you know for
everyone to see
including you know uh you know top
people top brass
with the packers and so everybody knows
what it is and so i believe that after
that they understand that hey man that
this is you know one of the best
quarterbacks in all of football
all he's asking is to have a little bit
of input on what it is the decisions
we're making in terms of personnel what
he needs to be successful as a
quarterback and i think for the for the
packers they better do everything they
can
and rogers has you know maybe three four
more years left you want to lock this
guy in
make him happy for as long as you can
because this stadium if you watched him
walk off that field yesterday after that
game and people chanting mvp
they love aaron rodgers and i think that
aaron as he walks off that field i think
he feels it i think he knows it so i
think the more and more than just
speaking plays out
aaron is more and more receptive
to being in green bay so his uh his
entire career
all right couple more minutes left with
uh charles what's in here on the rich
eisen show let's give me your thoughts
on the raiders and how viable a threat
do you think they are in the afc what a
win that was on thanksgiving they they
uh established josh jacobs in my mind in
a way that we haven't seen for the first
11 weeks of the season um and and what
you think of the defense they've got
they've got uh some pretty great pass
rushers on that team that that was sent
taxway what do you think of their
viability for the rest of the year
charles
yeah absolutely i think for the raiders
man what's most important for them man
is that you know they're going to have
to you know block out all the noise you
know going forward you know everybody
knows uh you know what they've gone
through in terms of you know a lot of
off the field stuff this year um
so a lot of people are you know talking
this is the same old raiders this and
that
but the raiders have good players on
that team you talk about josh jacobs and
really getting him going in that game
josh jacobs can be a dominant running
back um i think that you know for the
raiders what they have to do is they got
to establish that uh that balanced
attack you know with the run game as
well as the passing game
um make sure you keep you know your
quarterback derek carr keeps him upright
uh so that he's not you know running for
his life back there in the backfield
they could do that we know that this guy
can light up the school board you know
in terms of the yards and points and uh
you said it man max rosie and coxton uh
and backwards yannick you know these
guys are dynamic
russian duo that you have in the nfl so
they have some players out there man but
it's you know the name of the game and
it's all about fundamentals you know
as
you know al davidson says blocking the
tackle
you know and it's really as simple as
that
so
i think for this team they got to be
able to use um the sean jackson
downfield a little bit more if they can
you know try to open things up
underneath yeah brian edwards i think
has to be a big piece of this team as a
young receiver
he's got to step up big time but you
know they got as good a chance as
anybody nobody's just dominant this year
um this nigga's been up and down it's
been all over the place so
anybody can get there so um
yeah i mean ever it is wide open a lot
of people are saying though charles said
it's it looks like 2001 all over again
for the patriots the way that mack jones
is playing in his first go-round as
quarterback the same way that brady did
if that's the case does that mean the
raiders play new england in the snow and
jonathan abrams going to knock the ball
loose because he wears 24.
i think that that happens what do you
think charles
yeah is that going to happen yeah i
guess anything can happen but as long as
i can pick whoever the referee crew is
then we can play the game i can't pick
the referee crew then all that's at all
because you know they call it the snow
game in new england you know that right
you know they call it the snow game in
new england that's what they call it i
know i know what they call it i'm not
worried about the snow i'm worried about
the rest okay sounds good sounds good
charles
all right charles uh i appreciate you uh
you've given us a call while you're
signing your wines and your and your
and your uh and your alcohol right your
your
your whiskey the whiskey fantastic
fantastic and as i said it pairs
perfectly with whoop ass as i found out
perfectly on saturday night uh how far
do you think michigan goes again you
know what a national champion michigan
team looks like what do you think do you
think this is it what do you think this
can happen
honestly
heart of hearts yeah i i like to chan i
like the chances of course you know we
got to come down off of the high that's
right of course
uh take care of business down in indy
but you know as i look at the field rich
i don't think there's anybody that'll be
in that board
that they can't beat or they don't match
up with
so this is a good chance for us to go
and win a national championship as we've
ever had
in hardball
uh there's a good chance there's a good
chance i'm you know trying to work out i
might you never know i might be signing
some bottles of whiskey
i love it and people can go where to get
your stuff let's get the plug in you can
do it yeah you can go to cw intercept
wines.com or
whiskey.com you know or if you're in
green bay or deep here you can go to
festival fools or maybe
we're in a lot of places rich
man if the packers win the super bowl
and michigan wins the national
championship the week of the year that
you go into the ring of honor in the
hall of fame
i don't know charles you're gonna have
to give me your lottery numbers that's
what i need to know if that happens be
honest with you how sick how sick would
that be it would be uh you know
it would definitely be sick that will be
for sure
so uh let's talk down the line thanks
for the call charles you're the best
well good man good talking to you you
got it that's first ballot hall of famer
pro football hall of famer charles
woodson signing his
wine and whiskey there in green bay
wisconsin right here in the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here